ahora hagamos nuestro circuito más
complicado vamos a tener aquí nuestra
batería nuestra fuente de poder terminar
positiva negativa tenemos nuestro cable
conductor ideal
que vamos a menos por acá de este otro
lado también
y aquí vamos a tener
una resistencia resistor seguimos aquí
tenemos otra resistencia y aquí otra más
y sabemos que la convención indica que
la corriente va del polo positivo al
polo negativo por lo que la corriente
según la convención va a ir por acá ese
es el flujo de corriente y recordemos
que la corriente es el cambio de carga
entre cierto tiempo y nosotros sabemos
que en realidad lo que sucede es que
tenemos un montón de electrones aquí en
la terminal negativa y como la
diferencia de voltaje entre estas dos
terminales es grande estos electrones de
acá van a tener muchas ganas de llegar a
esta terminal positiva y mientras más
grande sea el voltaje más grandes serán
estas ganas que tendrán los electrones
de llegar a la otra terminal que va a
suceder en este circuito bueno de hecho
vamos a etiquetar todos los elementos a
esta resistencia le vamos a llamar r uno
mejor escribe una r más bonita
1 este es el 2
lo primero que quiero que se den cuenta
es que entre los elementos de este
circuito el voltaje siempre será
constante porque
asumimos que este cable es un conductor
perfecto por lo que en este segmento no
hay nada que detenga a los electrones
por lo que se van a distribuir a sí
mismos a lo largo de este material más o
menos así sin que se salgan los
electrones del material
incluso pueden ver todo este segmento
este de acá de este conductor como una
extensión de la terminal negativa y de
igual manera pueden ver este cable que
está aquí como un segmento de la
terminal positiva o una extensión de la
terminal positiva y la razón por la que
digo esto es porque resulta que no
importa si yo mido el voltaje aquí
usando un voltímetro
más adelante explicaré con detalle qué
es un voltímetro pero si yo miro el
voltaje aquí va a ser exactamente lo
mismo que si yo mido el voltaje
de aquí
acá el voltaje va a ser el mismo y de
hecho van ya que les comenté esto vamos
a quitar estos elementos para no
fundir aquí nuestro diagrama
o al menos estos voltajes en teoría son
los mismos realmente sabemos que no
existe un conductor perfecto por lo que
va a haber cierta variación en el
voltaje para al menos en este esquema en
teoría con nuestro conductor perfecto
los voltajes van a ser iguales así que
eso lo primero que quiero que entiendan
por ejemplo en estos segmentos de cable
entre las resistencias el voltaje será
constante ahora sabemos que el voltaje
entre las resistencias es constante y
otra cosa que quiero que entiendan es
que la corriente que corre en todo ese
circuito también va a ser constante y
eso aplica en todos los circuitos que
estén en serie bueno qué significa esto
en serie significa que todo dentro del
circuito va uno atrás del otro por
ejemplo si aquí seguimos la convención
del flujo de corriente r uno va a estar
primero y luego le va a seguir
r2 y después r3 no hay ninguna
bifurcación en el circuito así que está
totalmente en serie
podemos poner las corrientes también
aquí la corriente que va en r1 podemos
llamarla aquí y uno la corriente que
está por entrar a r2 llamamos idos y la
corriente de aquí vamos a llamarla ib3
hay un par de maneras de convencerlos de
que la corriente 1 es igual a la
corriente 2 y es igual a la corriente 3
una es experimental usando un
amperímetro para medir las corrientes en
estos elementos y encontrar que son
idénticas y la otra forma y en esta voy
a hablar de electrones
es explicar como suceden las cosas en
esta dirección de la terminal negativa a
la positiva que es como sabemos que en
la realidad se van moviendo los
electrones
tenemos a los electrones que están aquí
en donde van tan rápido como quieren
quizás cercano a la velocidad de la luz
ya que tienen una masa muy pequeña pero
una vez que llegan a este resistor van a
comenzar a traspasar con cosas y se van
a detener un poco los receptores son
como cuellos de botella y si se detienen
aquí en la resistencia pues van a tener
que detenerse en todo esto de atrás pues
si no lo hacen comenzarán a acumularse
aquí antes de entrar a la resistencia lo
que no tiene sentido porque sabemos que
están homogéneamente distribuidos y de
manera similar pueden salir de este
registro con cierta velocidad y al
llegar a este otro detenerse y bajar su
velocidad aún más
pero si fueran aún más lento aquí se
comenzarían a acumular lo que en esencia
ocasiona que se tenga esta velocidad en
todos los demás
elementos atrás de éste resistor
y otra forma de pensar en ello es que
las resistencias o los receptores son
cosas probabilísticas si lo vemos a un
nivel macroscópico decimos que la
resistencia hace más lenta la corriente
pero al tener un resistor va a aumentar
la probabilidad de que algunos de los
electrones se tropiecen con algo y creen
un poco de calor o bajen su velocidad
etcétera
así que cuando ponemos resistor es en
serie lo que hacemos es incrementar la
probabilidad de que más electrones se
topen con más cosas por lo que la
corriente en todo este circuito va a ser
la misma
ahora si decimos eso que más podemos
decir digamos que la corriente aquí en
r1 es 1 cuál va a ser el voltaje si me
diera este voltaje acá de aquí acá y
éste lo llamo voltaje 1 cuál va a ser
bueno si pusiéramos un multímetro acá
que es lo que nos daría
tenemos que esteve uno va a ser igual
por la ley de ohm a la resistencia uno
por la corriente 1 y de manera similar
si yo me diera mi voltaje en esta otra
resistencia 2000 voltaje 2
con este voltímetro sería igual a la
resistencia 2 por la corriente 2 y
finalmente si yo tomo mi voltaje
3 lo mido aquí dibujamos otro voltímetro
pues este también va a ser igual a la
resistencia 3 por la corriente
así que lo que vemos es que el voltaje a
través de todo el circuito que puedo
escribir como voltaje total de t va a
ser igual a la caída de potencial en
cada uno de estos elementos de estos
dispositivos otra forma de pensar en
ello es que los electrones aquí al lado
derecho de r3 tienen muchas ganas de
llegar al otro lado pero después de que
se tropezaron con cosas aquí en r3
experimentaron cierta caída de potencial
por lo que los electrones que salieron y
están por acá más o menos
ya no tendrán tantas ganas de llegar a
la otra terminal y después de que
pasaron por r2 estarán cansados de
haberse tropezado con tantas cosas por
lo que cuando llegan acá ya no van a
tener tantas ganas
y continuar su camino así que el voltaje
va a ir cayendo después de cada
dispositivo por lo tanto el voltaje
total será igual a la caída de voltaje
en cada uno de estos elementos
ahora vamos a regresar a la convención
de que la corriente va en este sentido
por lo que nuestro voltaje total va a
ser igual a el voltaje 1
más el voltaje 2 más el voltaje 3 y por
lo tanto siguiendo la ley de ohm el
voltaje total también es igual a la
resistencia 1 por corriente 1 más
resistencia 2 por corriente 2 más muy
bien ya lo adivinaron resistencia 3 por
corriente 3 y cuál es la caída total del
voltaje será igual a la corriente en
todo el sistema y te quedamos que la
corriente total es la misma en todo el
circuito por lo que podemos reescribir
esta ecuación ahora tomando en cuenta
esta corriente total multiplicando la
por una resistencia total aplicando la
ley de ohm ponemos corriente total por
resistencia total
igual a estos elementos los vuelvo a
reescribir
r 1 y 1 por más si estoy poniendo por no
más r 2 por y 2 más r 3 por y 3
bueno como les comentaba nuestra
corriente va a ser la misma en todo el
sistema por lo que podemos deshacernos
de estos términos de aquí y quedar con
que la resistencia total va a ser igual
a la resistencia 1 más la resistencia 2
más la resistencia 3
esta es la resistencia total del
circuito así que cuando tenemos
resistencias en serie la resistencia
total o la resistencia combinada de todo
el circuito va a ser la suma de cada una
de ellas esta fue una forma muy extensa
de explicar algo muy sencillo y ahora
vamos a hacer un ejemplo vamos a decir
que tenemos en nuestra batería un
voltaje igual a 20 bultos
en nuestra resistencia 1 tenemos un
valor de 2 oms la resistencia 2 es de 3
oms
la resistencia 3 va a ser igual a 5 oms
cuál va a ser la resistencia total de
todo el sistema bueno pues vamos a sumar
todas las resistencias
3 5 am nos va a quedar que la
resistencia total es igual a 10 oms si
yo les preguntara cuál es la corriente
que pasa por todo el circuito pues la
resistencia total ya vimos que es de 10
oms y conocemos la ley de ohm que nos
dice que el voltaje es igual a la
resistencia por la corriente
entonces sabemos el voltaje que es de 20
volts
tenemos la resistencia que es de 10 oms
y la corriente que es nuestra incógnita
la despejamos y nos queda corriente es
igual a 20 volts entre 10 oms que nos da
un total de 2 amperios o ams que a su
vez son iguales a 2 kilos sobre segundo
lo que parecía una explicación muy
extensa resultó algo muy fácil de
aplicar cuando los receptores están en
serie se van a sumar nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo